Narrator:
INSTALLING A POOL ABOVE GROUND
COSTS MUCH LESS
THAN INSTALLING ONE IN GROUND.
THIS IS BECAUSE THERE'S
NO EXCAVATION REQUIRED.
YOU CAN BUILD AN ELEVATED DECK
AROUND THE TOP
TO GIVE IT
AN IN-GROUND APPEARANCE,
OR YOU CAN SIMPLY CLIMB
UP A LADDER AND JUMP RIGHT IN.
NO HOLE TO DIG,
NO UNDERGROUND PIPES TO INSTALL.
JUST A DAY OR SO
OF ON-SITE PREP AND ASSEMBLY,
AND YOU CAN TAKE
TO YOUR ABOVE-GROUND POOL
LIKE A DUCK TO WATER.
AT THE FACTORY,
A COMPUTER-GUIDED MACHINE
CUTS VINYL PANELS FOR THE POOL'S
WATER-RETAINING INSIDE SURFACE.
THE VINYL COMES IN A WIDE CHOICE
OF PRINTED DESIGNS.
IT'S TEAR-RESISTANT,
U.V.-RESISTANT,
AND IS TREATED
WITH AN ANTIFUNGAL COATING.
THE WALL PANEL IS RECTANGULAR,
AND THE FLOOR PANELS ARE CURVED
TO FIT THE POOL'S PERIMETER.
THE WALL PANELS GO THROUGH
A WELDER THAT FUSES A BEAD
TO THE TOP EDGE.
A BEAD IS A FLEXIBLE,
U-SHAPED, THERMOPLASTIC STRIP
THAT IS USED TO ATTACH
THE POOL WALL TO THE LINER.
A HOT WELDING TOOL
SLIGHTLY MELTS BOTH THE BEAD
AND THE LINER EDGE,
SO WHEN THEY COOL AND SOLIDIFY,
THEY'RE BONDED.
THE LINER IS READY
TO BE ASSEMBLED.
WORKERS USE
A MANUAL WELDING MACHINE
THAT GENERATES HEAT
WITH RADIO FREQUENCIES.
THEY OVERLAP THE EDGES
OF ADJOINING PANELS,
THEN FUSE THEM TOGETHER.
AFTER CONNECTING
THE FLOOR PANELS TO EACH OTHER,
WORKERS COMPLETE THE LINER BY
JOINING THE WALL TO THE FLOOR.
A QUALITY-CONTROL INSPECTOR
CHECKS EVERY SOLDERED SEAM
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE SOLID.
MEANWHILE, WORKERS MANUFACTURE
THE POOL'S
STRUCTURAL COMPONENTS.
THEY FEED A CONTINUOUS STRIP
OF PAINTED, GALVANIZED STEEL
THROUGH A ROLL FORMER.
THE STRIP IS SHAPED
TO A SPECIFIC PROFILE.
A PUNCH PRESS
CUTS THE COMPONENTS
TO THE REQUIRED LENGTH
AND SHAPE.
FOUR DIFFERENT STRUCTURAL
COMPONENTS ARE MADE THIS WAY --
THE PIECES THAT FORM THE TOP
AND BOTTOM TRACKS OF THE POOL,
THE VERTICAL POSTS
THAT SUPPORT THE POOL WALL,
AND THE LEDGES RUNNING
ALONG THE TOP OF THE WALL.
THE WALL IS ALSO MADE
OF PAINTED GALVANIZED STEEL.
A ROLLER IMPRESSES A CORRUGATED
PATTERN TO GIVE THE WALL
MORE VERTICAL STRENGTH.
THEN, A PRESS
PUNCHES OUT OPENINGS
FOR THE POOL'S WATER INLET
AND FILTER.
AFTER FOLDING EACH END
OF THE WALL OVER ITSELF
TO FORM A STRONG EDGE,
THEY PUNCH HOLES FOR THE BOLTS
THAT WILL JOIN THE EDGES.
A STAMPING DIE
PROGRESSIVELY SHAPES STRIPS
OF GALVANIZED STEEL
INTO CONNECTORS.
THE CONNECTORS
JOIN THE VERTICAL POSTS
TO THE STRUCTURE'S BOTTOM TRACK
AND TOP RAIL.
AN INJECTION MOLDER
MAKES THE PLASTIC COVERS
THAT WILL HIDE THOSE CONNECTORS.
WORKERS THEN BOX THE LINER
AND STRUCTURAL COMPONENTS
FOR TRANSPORT
TO THE INSTALLATION SITE.
ON-SITE, THEY LAY CRUSHED STONE
AROUND THE PERIMETER
TO SUPPORT THE BOTTOM TRACK
UNDER THE WEIGHT OF THE WATER.
NEXT, THEY UNROLL THE POOL WALL
AND PLACE IT
IN THE BOTTOM TRACK.
THEY PLACE A VERTICAL POST
OVER EACH BOTTOM CONNECTOR
AND SECURE IT WITH SCREWS.
INSIDE THE POOL WALL,
THEY LAY DOWN A BASE OF SAND
AND COMPACT IT.
THEN, THEY
LAY DOWN LANDSCAPING FABRIC.
THEY CUT A HOLE
FOR A CENTRAL BOTTOM DRAIN.
THEN, THEY BEGIN SPREADING
OUT THE LINER.
THEY HOOK THE BEAD
OVER THE TOP EDGE OF THE WALL,
THEN LOCK IT IN PLACE
WITH THE TOP RAIL.
ONCE THE LINER
IS FULLY ATTACHED,
THEY SUCTION OUT THE AIR TO DRAW
IT TIGHT AGAINST THE WALL.
THEY SEAL THE LINER
TO THE BOTTOM DRAIN.
THEY HIDE THE TOP RAIL
UNDER THE LEDGE
AND THE CONNECTIONS
UNDER PLASTIC CAPS.
THEY RUN PIPES TO CONNECT THE
FILTRATION SYSTEM AND SKIMMER.
THEN, WITH AN ORDINARY
GARDEN HOSE,
THEY FILL THE POOL WITH WATER.